قرار حظر حسابات عدد من الصحفيين على
تويتر لم يمر مرور الكرام
انتقادات وضغوط دوليه اضافه الى تهديدات
من الاتحاد الاوروبي بفرض عقوبات على
الرئيس التنفيذي لمنصه الطائر الازرق
ايلين ماسك غيرت بوصله قراره اذ اعلن ماسك
انه سيعيد حسابات العديد من الصحفيين
الذين تم حظرهم على المنصه مؤخرا لكن قبل
الاعلان كان ماسك قد اطلق استطلاعا على
المنصه حول ما اذا كان سيتم استعاده
حسابات الصحفيين اكثر من 58% من الاصوات
ايدت سعادتها على الفور لكن مصر لم يفعلها
فورا انتهاء التصويت
قرارات ماسك منذ استحوا هذه على تويتر
مفعولها كبير وتاثيرها السلبي اكبر خصوصا
عليه حيث تراجعت اسهم شركه تسلا بنسبه
اكثر من اربعه في المئه وسجلت اسوا خساره
الاسبوعيه لها منذ مارس 2020 مع تزايد قلق
المستثمرين
رئيسه قسم الثقه والامان في تويتر اكدت ان
فريق المنصه راجع يدويا جميع الحسابات
التي تنتهي كل سياسه الخصوصيه الجديده
موضحه ان السياسه الجديده شملت حسابات غير
الصحفيين فيما كشف الجمعيات حقوقيه ان
تصرفات تويتر الاخيره تنتهي كوم مبدا ان
منصات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ستسمح
بالتوزيع غير المصفى للمعلومات الموجوده
بالفعل
عواصفه لا تبشر بالنهايه قريبه يتخبط بها
عملاق التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر رياحها
قرارات ما تكون عشوائيا لكنها جعلت من
الرؤيه على المدى البعيد ضبابيه